(bangles clanking)
- [Mark] All right, Brianna.
Brianna, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from?
- I'm from Pasadena.
- [Mark] Pasadena?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents growing up?
- No I didn't.
I lost my mom at a young age.
She was addicted to drugs.
- [Mark] Oh I'm sorry.
- And I never knew my father.
- [Mark] You never knew your dad?
- No.
- [Mark] So who raised you?
- My Auntie, which I
consider to be my mom.
- [Mark] And how was your childhood?
- Um, my childhood was pretty good.
- [Mark] No abuse, nothing like that?
- No.
- [Mark] And then what kind of
kid were you in high school?
(vehicle hooting)
- Um, so like in high school I notice,
well like actually, when I was like 13
my mom told me I had it with men
and I didn't realize what she meant
until I actually turned 16.
- [Mark] Your aunt told you this?
- Hmm.
- [Mark] Told you what?
- That I have a way with men.
- [Mark] You have a way with men?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Yes, yes you do.
I'm sure you do.
(Brianna chuckles)
And what did, what did that mean?
- Um, so once I became 16,
I realized that I just kind of had a...
- [Mark] The guys liked you.
- Yeah.
Like older, you know
generous gentlemen were attracted to me.
- [Mark] And what did
that, what did that mean
in terms of what kind of
interactions were you having?
- Um, when I was from 16 to 18,
I didn't technically
have sexual intercourse
with any of my clients,
but after 18 definitely.
- [Mark] And where were you working?
Down Figaro?
- Yes.
I've worked on a couple of lanes.
- [Mark] South central?
- Yes.
- [Mark] And were you working
with a pimp or on your own?
- On my own.
- [Mark] On your own.
Have you ever, ever had a pimp?
- No.
- [Mark] How much money would
you make or do you make?
- I make, I've had like
10 established clients.
So like I make anywhere from like
10 to 15 bands, like a week
I would say like totaling
all my allowances together.
- [Mark] So you have regulars?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So rather than
picking up strangers,
you're picking up your same usual.
- Yeah.
So from like 16 to 18, I was
just like out on the blade.
I really didn't know any
like other hoeing source
and then my cousin introduced
me to like posting ads
and meeting guys like off the internet.
- [Mark] Yeah.
So, so today, are you
like on the streets still
or are you basically just
doing it over the phone?
- No, I like both like,
mainly really the streets more
just because everything
that's going on, like it's not
too popular to try to
like set up a date online.
It's more easier for
them to just pick me up.
- [Mark] Yeah.
And have you had bad experiences to, from
from guys that have picked you up?
- Yes I have.(heaves)
- [Mark] what kind of stuff has happened?
- Um, one time I was,
I feel like I was kidnapped by three guys.
One of them actually hit me in my face.
So like,
like I like kind of
traumatized me like a bit
and made me really like scared of men
and like, you know
just living in a predicament
that I was living in
being on the streets, like
hoeing or, you know, like having
like staying at people's houses
or like sleeping with them in hotels
and just things like that.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Have you been arrested before.
- No, I don't have a record at all.
- [Mark] Nothing.
- No.
- [Mark] When guys pick you up
where do you guys typically
go to the car or to a hotel?
- Um, wherever is convenient.
- [Mark] Just wherever?
- Yeah, wherever gets me more money.
- [Mark] (chuckles) Do you have kids?
- Yes. I have a three-year-old son.
- [Mark] And you raise him?
- Yes.
- [Mark] So you started at what age?
- At sixteen.
- [Mark] Sixteen.
And are drugs a part
of the picture for you?
- Of course.
- [Mark] (chuckles) Which,
which drug is yours?
- Um, I love cocaine.(chuckles)
- [Mark] So are you doing
crack or just powder.
- No just cocaine, just powder.
- [Mark] Okay.
- And smoking weed of course.
- [Mark] Of course?
- And liquor, you know.
- [Mark] Does your family know
you do this, your aunt or?
- Yeah, like she didn't have a choice.
I got arrested, but it wasn't for hoeing,
and I needed her to go and get my car
and my money from like
one of my sugar daddies.
So I had to kind of tell her like,
"Hey you gotta go see this guy."
And he pulled up and she's
like, "he was white."
You know?
(chuckles) Like, what is that?
- [Mark] What was her reaction?
- Um honestly, being 29
now I would have read their
preferred a different
reaction from what I got
but it was just kind of like, okay,
you know like, your mom was a hoe.
- [Mark] It is what it is.
- That's what I'm proper.(chuckles)
And it took care of both of us, you know
like of course my benefits
were her benefits.
- [Mark] Yeah. Does this
lifestyle get you down?
Sometimes you get depressed.
- Yeah I would say.
When I have to take my
son like on dates with me
and things like that.
Yeah. It really like,
you know, it gets to me.
Like before it was okay when
he was like an infant, you know
he's in his car seat, boom, you know.
Go from house to house,
he'll be with me all night.
But sometimes I would have to leave him
in the car while I get in another car.
But it was pretty easy back then.
And now he's three and he's like,
who is this?(chuckles)
You know like, like,
what are you doing?
What are you doing?
You know?
So yeah, that part really bothers me.
- [Mark] How do you
think working the streets
has changed you?
- (scoffs) It made me realize that like,
like things that I was taught
growing up in my childhood,
were just like bullshit.
You know?
Cause you,
I mean, you can go to
high school and graduate
but, what is a high school diploma
compared to making thousands
of dollars a night,
and I look at it like if
they're not going to pay me,
they're gonna pay somebody else.
So I might as well take this money.
- [Mark] So are you happy
with this lifestyle?
Do you think you're
happy, just in general?
- (chuckles) I think I,
I think I'm more so
forced myself to be happy
with the lifestyle, just because
of all the accommodations
and perks that it comes with.
You know, like I've had
encounters with celebrities.
I've had encounters with rappers.
I've had encounters with producers.
I've been to a ton of swinger parties.
I mean, I did porno with
pinky the porn star.
So like at the age of 21.
So like, I kind of just
dived in head first.
- [Mark] So you're regretting
choices like that one?
- Definitely I would say.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- But I would say like, probably
more good ones than bad.
- [Mark] Really?
- You know?
Like, I feel like I am
fair to whatever I do.
I never have any bad intentions.
You know, when I meet a
guy, I'm not thinking like,
Oh I want to Rob him or get over on him.
Like, I'm just like,
you do your part, I'll do my part.
If you like me, call me again.
- [Mark] Have you been in love before?
- Um yes.
- [Mark] And do you find this lifestyle,
doing this for a living
gets in the way of that?
- Definitely.
- [Mark] Yeah.
I would think a guy
would have a hard time.
- Yeah of course.
- [Mark] What advice would
you give a young girl
who's thinking about doing this?
- [Brianna] I would tell her
to know what she's doing.
I mean, you don't get
to many options in life.
So if this is one of your
options it's not a bad one.
- [Mark] All right, Brianna.
Thank you so much for
sharing your your story
and good luck with wherever
your life goes from here.
- All right, thank you.
- [Mark] Thank you.